RICHARD EBERHARDT: My
name's Rick Eberhardt.
I'm the studio manager
for the MIT Game Lab.
I've been with the
lab since 2007, 2006,
so since we formed a
long, long time ago.
Before I worked at the
lab, most of my background
has been doing
information technology
for academics, institutes,
so colleges and universities.
I always had an
interest in games.
I actually had a cultural
studies degree in college
for my undergrad.
So coming to the lab, working
at the lab for that first year
as a system administrator
really opened
my eyes to all the different
things games can do
and the different potentials
games have, but also made me
realize I can actually start
making these kinds of things
on my own too.
So since I've started
working at the lab,
I've taken on more
duties related
to project management,
things I'd already
done a lot in IT-- managing
people managing projects.
I teach this Creating
Video Games course,
and for the most
part in the course,
I'm interested in teaching the
product management techniques,
but also the soft skills
and the social skills.
I'm an introvert.
I have a really hard time having
conversations with people.
And I've had to, in my
years in my profession,
figure out ways to not
let that be a restriction,
and actually use
that to my advantage
when I'm talking with teams.
And I find it really successful,
actually, in game development.
I don't know if it could
be successful elsewhere,
but there's a lot of other
like-minded people like me
in game development.
So it's good to
have, for me, to be
able to use those
skills in that setting.
The other advantage I
have at the Game Lab
is I get to do research.
I get to help with research
on various different types
of projects.
So my personal
research interests
tend to be towards
closer to what
this class is talking about--
this meaningful decision
making.
I've done some research
in using board games
to teach decision making,
in particular, like economic
concepts, like opportunity cost.
I'm interested in social
experiences in games,
and cooperative gameplay.
Past games I've worked on
have been about all sorts
of different things.
So anything from tools to
help game developers make
3D characters animate
faster-- basically
to speed up the
workflow process--
to games about
depression and games
about other serious topics.
I really like working
with researchers.
I like working with clients,
and I like making games.
What am I playing now?
So I am playing this
game called Gridland,
made by the same developer who
made a previous game called
A Dark Room.
It's kind of
difficult to describe.
It's basically a
match-three game
where you're like Bejeweled,
you're matching gems.
But there is a small
supply chain mechanic
going on in the background.
Where as I have
the gems combined,
I can upgrade my weapons,
and I can upgrade my armor.
And then when night comes--
so I'm matching gems
in the daytime to upgrade
things-- and when night comes,
I'm matching gems to summon
enemies and to kill enemies.
So this Gridland game has a
daytime and a nighttime view
of the game.
And what I find really
interesting about it
is that all my decisions
I make in the day
are going to have
some kind of influence
in my nighttime decisions.
So as I make my daytime
experience easier,
I'm actually making my
nighttime experience harder.
So it's just a really
interesting little challenge
that the designers put
for me to try to solve.
So outside of the class, the
kinds of games I'm making
are non-digital
prototypes, so card games,
in particular, that
are experimenting
with things like a tech
tree and a 4X-style game.
So if you've played a
game like Civilization,
or StarCraft even, they'll have
these tech expansion trees.
So I'm playing around with
designing a game that's
largely just the tech tree.
I'm doing that with a
coworker here, Drew.
I've also got a game
I've been working on,
off and on for the
past couple years,
about managing cities--
about three players trying
to manage a city.
They're counsel people.
I'm trying to convince the mayor
about what decisions the mayor
should make for the city, but,
unfortunately, the mayor is
just the role of
a six-sided die.
So you can try to
convince him or her
what you want, but
it really doesn't
matter because the mayor's
got its own agenda.
So then you're trying to solve
the problems with the city,
while also trying to solve
your own personal-- trying
to basically get political
gain while solving the city's
problems.
There's a lot of different
co-op experiences out there--
from anything from over the
table like cooperative board
games to couch style
co-op in front of the TV.
I'm trying to think my favorite
co-op experience is definitely
not Pandemic,
which I think we're
talking about in class today.
I have a hard time deciding what
my favorite co-op experience is
because so often, one of the
challenges of co-op games
is somebody takes
control, and somebody
says what the whole everybody
on the team is going to do.
And unfortunately, I'm
one of those people.
If I know the game, I'll start
being bossy and I'll take over.
And what I'd love to
see more co-op games
do is put in mechanics to
prevent me from being a jerk.
Or enable other people to
override my jerkiness somehow.
So the thing I look forward to
most in this class every year
is the playtest
sessions, especially when
it's the first time the team has
brought the game into the class
and they're putting it in front
of new users, which we only
have a couple opportunities
for each project for that
to happen in class.
After that everyone
in the classroom
has seen the game
before, so they
are not giving the
same kind of feedback.
And what I really like about
it is when the games come in
and they just don't work.
They're broken horribly.
Not when it's the
technical problems--
not when it's the code crashing
or it's the broken build.
That's actually really sad,
and I hate to see that.
But when it's a
design issue, when
they thought it was going
to do this one thing
and see the game doing
this other thing,
or they see the players
doing this other thing,
it's at that point that the
students understand that OK,
people do people things.
Humans are human, right?
You can't always
predict everything
that they're going to do.
But also that the
systems that they created
are actually incredibly complex.
So the things that they need
to do to fix the systems
are going to be reducing
mechanics, removing things
from the game, making it
a little bit more simple,
so that they can predict
a little bit better
about what's going on.
But then on the
flip side of that,
though, there's
sometimes when you
see something
happen in the game,
and you just get this
emergent gameplay
that is better than what
they were going for.
They didn't realize
they wanted it.
When they see it
in action, they're
like, oh, this is
actually really great.
What can we do when
we're finishing this game
to really capitalize on
this mechanic or this system
that we just didn't
even realize was there?
I really like systems.
Outside of the
class, I think this
might be the thing
that I actually,
I always had in some capacity.
But really coming to
MIT, working at MIT,
it's much more
part of my life is
seeing the systems that surround
us and the systems of history.
I've always had an
interest in history,
and a little bit of
interest in anthropology.
But reading Charles Mann's
books about 1491 and 1493,
what happened during
the Colombian Exchange,
when all of these
different ideas
and products and
agricultural things
swapped places
from East to West,
from China to the
Americas to Europe.
There's just some really
interesting systems.
And a lot of the problems
we're facing today
are the direct result
of that big expansion
of ideas and trading of ideas.
So I've always been interested
in those kind of things.
And I'm watching The Wire.
I really like The Wire.
And just seeing the systems that
are involved in city planning,
in police work, in education,
in all these civic institutions
that we just take for
granted every day.
Yes, The Wire is a very
critical and a very pessimistic
view of it.
But it is a great expression of
just how all of these problems
are connected.
And some of the problems
that we are facing right now,
it's just we can't
see the connections.
And I hope that, at least with
games, with playing games,
with making games, people
can better understand
how those systems work.
For the future of games, games
as expressions of systems,
games as ways of exploring
the world around us.
We've always--
1,000 of years ago,
we used games as ways to
communicate with each other,
to have rituals with each
other to better connect
with each other.
And I think we can do that
with just games in general--
not just video
games, but all sorts
of different kinds of games.
So seeing that come
back to both what people
are talking about when they
talk about games in mainstream.
Other than just this
thing that's done for fun,
it's actually this
thing that's very
important to human daily life.
And we've been
doing it for years.
It's just it looks
different now,
but it's still based on
a lot of the same things.